الصين تتدخل بشكل مباشر في الحرب
الاوكرانيه لدعم حليفتها روسيا والحديث
هنا لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن من مدينه ميونخ الالمانيه
ان الشركات الصينيه تقدم بالفعل دعما
باسلحه غير قتاليه فيما جديد المعلومات
يشير الى ان بكين يمكن ان تقدم دعما قاتلا
وبينما حذر بلنكن بكين من عواقب وخيمه
عليها اذا اقدمت على تقديم الدعم لروسيا
تنفي الصين بشكل كامل التقارير التي تحدثت
عن ان روسيا طلبت منها معدات عسكريه
استعدادا للمعارك المقبله في اوكرانيا قبل
ذلك وبعيدا عن وسائل الاعلام التقى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بنظيره الصيني الذي اكد
لبلينكن ان العلاقات بين البلدين تضررت
بسبب طريقه تعامل واش احاديث المنطاد وحظ
الجانب الامريكي على تغيير المسار واصلاح
الضرر الذي تسبب فيه ما سماه الاستخدام
المفرط للقوه للعلاقات بين بكين وواشنطن
بحسب قول الوزير الصيني
راينا شركات صينيه وهناك لا فرق بين
الشركات الخاصه والدوله رايناهم يقدمون
دعما باسلحه غير مميته لروسيا لاستخدامها
في اوكرانيا القلق الان يعتمد على
المعلومات التي لدينا عن انهم يفكرون في
تقديم اسلحه قاتله
والان نواب جمهوريون وكذلك ديمقراطيون
يطالبون اداره الرئيس بايدن بارسال
مقاتلات اف 16 لاوكرانيا تلك التي كنا
نقول للتو بان زيلينسكي يقاتل من اجل
الحصول عليها
قالت في تقرير لها ان الطائرات دون طيار
الصينيه تدعم الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وفقا لبيانات تجاريه بالاضافه الى بيانات
التصدير اظهرت عده مقاطع مصوره مقاتلين
روسا يستخدمون طائرات بدون طيار من طراز
دي جي اي الصينيه في اوكرانيا ما يوفر
لموسكو طريقه فعاله لاستهداف القوات
الاوكرانيه وفقا لمسؤولين غربيين ومحللين
امنيين وعدا عن المردود المادي من بيع
الطائرات باضعاف سعرها بامكان الصين عبر
المسيرات ان تجمع معلومات استخباراتيه في
ساحه المعركه
ترى كيفيه استجابه هذه الطائرات لهجمات
الحرب الالكترونيه شركه دي جي اي قالت في
بيان لها انها تعارض استخدام طائراتها
المدنيه في ساحه المعركه مشيره الى تعليق
اعمالها في روسيا واوكرانيا في ابريل من
العام الماضي رغم ذلك اشارت الى انه يمكن
شراء منتجات الشركه من متاجر التجاره
الالكترونيه في العديد من البلدان وانه لا
يمكن منع المستخدمين او المؤسسات من
الشراء بدورها اشارت سفاره الصين في
واشنطن ردا على تقرير
الى موقف وزاره الخارجيه من الحرب في
اوكرانيا والداعي للتفاوض ووقف التصعيد
بينما امتنعت وزاره الدفاع والخارجيه
الروسيتان عن التعليق
[موسيقى]